-Welcome back, everybody!
We're here with Oscar Isaac!
Come on, now.
[ Cheering and applause ]
We love you.
His movie "The Card Counter"
is On Demand now.
"The Card Counter,"
you play a guy
who has actually mastered how
to count cards
and goes casino to casino,
winning little amounts
of money...
-Little bit
-...just enough
to make a living.
Paul Schrader, director.
-Yeah, the great Paul Schrader.
-I mean, dude, "Taxi Driver,"
"Raging Bull."
Come on, he's legendary.
Produced by Scorsese?
-Mm-hmm.
-Yeah, not too shabby.
Do you know how to play cards,
at all, or just acting?
-A little bit, a little,
you know, poker.
-You do?
-Yeah, a little bit of poker.
-Oh, wow. Did you gamble
during the movie?
-So we shot in an actual casino,
actual casinos
in Biloxi, Mississippi...
-Yeah.
-...and, in between takes,
I'd go and sit with the locals
and play a little bit.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
-And are you...good?
-Bet low, lose low, you know?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Tiffany Haddish is in this,
who we love.
Who is so funny, but in this
movie, dramatic role.
-Yeah, it's a role that,
you know,
she doesn't really get
to play often
and she's just so great in it.
-Isn't something?
I go,
I've never met anyone
like Tiffany Haddish.
-I mean, I said to her,
I was like --
Well, the first thing she said,
when I was like,
"Hi, Tiffany.
How are you doing?"
She's like, "Successful."
[ Laughter ]
-That's a good answer.
Yeah, yeah, a little successful.
-Immediately, I was like,
"I love this person."
[ Laughter ]
And she just exudes
such a vibrancy.
It's like I imagine it was like
what meeting Jesus was like.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, wow.
-Where you're just like,
"I'll follow you.
I'll follow you anywhere."
[ Laughter ]
You know, I just want to be
around that light, you know?
-She does have a good --
-Like a sexy Jesus.
-Yeah, of course, yeah, exactly.
-Like really sexy Jesus.
-Do you want to set up what
"The Card Counter" is about?
-Well, yeah. Like you said,
it's about this man
who went to prison
and learned how to count cards
and, when he gets out,
he feels that he still
deserves punishment
for the horrible things
that he did.
It's a dark movie.
It's Paul Schrader,
again, you know.
This isn't like a flashy,
fun casino movie.
It's heavy stuff,
but really moving, I think.
And, any way,
he's given himself over
to this like
purgatorial existence
where he just goes and,
you know, plays these cards
and just kind of is going to
run out the clock on his life
and then,
he meets these two people
that give him a window
into possible redemption.
-Yeah.
It's really good.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Oscar Isaac
in "The Card Counter."
Take a look.
-Am I trying to justify
what we did?
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
No.
♪♪
[ Crying ]
Nothing...
♪♪
...nothing can justify
what we did.
♪♪
Your father understood that.
If you were there,
you could understand.
♪♪
Otherwise, there's no
understanding.
-Yeah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Oscar Isaac, everybody.
"The Card Counter" is
On Demand now.
Congrats on everything, buddy.
-Thank you, brother.
-Couldn't happen to a nicer guy.
Oscar Isaac, everybody.